i didn't expect to be that blown away by
it
wow
like there are pieces you can play where
you go hey this is a little bit easier
but just to play the open strings and go
whoa
today's video is brought to you by
classical guitar pro that's my brand new
online classical guitar course which is
six hours 53 videos it's a whole
curriculum designed to teach you what
you would normally learn in the first
six months to a year of classical guitar
lessons so if you want to learn
classical guitar but are stuck
struggling reading music or struggling
to learn the techniques check out
classicalguitardashpro.com
to learn more
hey friends i am joined today by expert
luthier marshall brene we are in his
fancy new showroom and for me this is
like uh being in a candy store i mean
everywhere i look there's a guitar
that's even more interesting and
fascinating than the next so i'm sure
we'll jam on these guitars a little bit
later but actually we're here today
because marshall has invited me to try
out some guitars but i don't really know
what we're doing exactly yet so marshall
fill me in because i can't wait to try
out whatever it is you have in store
okay yeah i was looking at a lot of the
comments from the rob scale and video
that we did together
uh the uh this guitar is worth 275 000
video and there was a lot of comments
saying i can't hear the difference
so i called you over to see if we can
hear the difference okay between a two
hundred dollar guitar
two thousand dollar guitar
twenty thousand dollar guitar there we
go and two hundred thousand dollar
guitar
i hope we can hear the difference we'll
find out absolutely as a whole we
generally
price graded off of the acoustics but
this is one where you at home will
probably want to listen to it on a good
set of headphones uh don't just grab
your your aliexpress earbuds yeah i
think one apple earbud for this video is
probably not going to cut it
do two two
stereo is always a good idea uh okay
well that sounds fascinating yeah i
can't wait to try out these instruments
let's start off with the 200 guitar okay
that sounds good here it is
the appropriate way to pick up a 200
guitar problem right
that's right
yeah this is a protege by cordoba it's a
c1 okay
you know it's for for the money it's
actually a reasonably
okay place to start this one was used as
a walking guitar well and they did it in
style with this color yeah it's a this
accessorizes well with everything it
goes with your shirt and is that mine
you can't go wrong it's a bold fashion
statement well it's bold something
that's right and we got a maple bridge
uh not stained maple fretboard
um
this i mean you know i used to work in a
guitar shop and this is kind of similar
to the ones that some of the ones that
we used to sell around the same price
range i noticed they're by different
companies but pretty similar you know
laminate tops um and uh very heavy yeah
very inexpensive sides and backs over
built uh you know it's built to be a
durable guitar yeah well i'm excited
just let's let's see how this thing uh
plays
so
right off the bat a bit a bit buzzy uh
but that's something we can we can fix
now yeah this guitar has a truss rod in
it and i think looking down the yeah it
does
a truss rod is a
red metal rod that goes inside the neck
which you can adjust to change the the
angle of the neck yeah well
to put relief into the fingerboard okay
so it should not be used to adjust the
action
but
to use to adjust the curvature of the
fingerboard so that way it doesn't buzz
uh this one looks like it was pulled
into a dead straight line yeah the neck
is like completely flat yeah which we
don't want right we want a little bit of
relief right you want the surface of the
neck
to mimic the envelope of movement of the
string because it moves more here at the
12th fret than it does at the nut or the
saddle oh wow but this thing is dead
dead flat
yeah oh yeah it makes mid-america look
rather uh
geographically interesting or
geologically interesting
unless you live there then it's
beautiful that's right let's hear a
little bit of how this thing plays here
i'll play some uh some mozart variations
by swords
[Music]
so right off the bat uh my impression is
that the sound sounds
you know it's like this the resonance is
really not making it out of the
instrument it sounds a bit trapped yeah
it's like a guitar with a head cold yeah
exactly
is it because of the laminate body or
the laminate top you think or yeah the
the top is
probably a very inexpensive well most
likely an inexpensive piece of wood
sandwiched with another inexpensive
piece of wood in between with a very
inexpensive piece of wood on the inside
right uh
probably not the best quality materials
and chances are the interior is highly
over built
for durability not for sound interesting
you know as we go through all these
different guitars today i was thinking
what's my criteria how do i actually
judge a good guitar and for me i think
it's very
important that first and foremost the
guitar is really easy to play it's so
playability is like got to be my my
first thing if if it's a cheap guitar
but i can really play it then at least i
can i can make music on it if it's
fighting me and i can't do what i want
to do then it's just like i i don't care
how you know famous the guitar is i
don't want to play it yeah
so playability is one thing then i think
about you know the overall timbre of the
instrument you have guitars which are
baser you have guitars which are
brighter um then there's resonance how
how much vibration is going on the
instrument is it totally dead like this
one
it's just like nothing's really
happening it sounds like it's kind of
trapped i like that it sounds like it
has a head cold i guess with this one i
mean my
my first reaction is actually the
playability is not so bad the action
isn't too high i can play it but i
really feel like it's it's not doing
anything for me it's like uh it just
sounds totally flat the sound is not
going anywhere the sustain let's just
let's test it out
[Music]
it's not terrible actually no but
there's no resonance behind it there's
no like sympathetic resonation going on
it's all like
it's all the fundamental there's no
overtone exactly right which is what we
want
so
later i'll be testing it out with a
piece
by barrios
and this one
well doesn't sound so great later on in
this video we're actually going to do a
uh just a back-to-back performance i'll
play a few pieces and we'll hear each
one right in a row so you can really
test what's the difference but but first
i want to see what each you know
instrument you prepared feels like here
so all right i think i think we have a
good impression here already we don't
need to spend too much more time with a
200 guitar no this one's already beaten
like a horse yeah all right let's toss
it
okay so one down
so
here's our two thousand dollar guitar
okay it's a
francisco play-doh
there is absolutely no relation to the
flatus i was going to ask you i thought
plato was kind of a famous name it is a
famous name okay but not francisco okay
there never was and you know if the
flight is smart there probably should
never be a francisco because you don't
want to get mixed up with this this is
an anonymous
japanese-made guitar okay imported by a
a gentleman who had a creative streak
with the naming of guitars for giving
them very similar to famous names okay
so getting a little sketchy right
this one has a laminated sides and back
but a solid top
it's actually
it's it's a nice guitar yeah it sounds
for
for the price point it actually sounds
pretty good it looks pretty too uh you
know it's got the exterior woods are
really nice uh the finish on it is
reasonably good the the top on it is a
nice high quality spruce top uh despite
the color it's actually been sprayed
over pretty heavily but it is a spruce
not a cedar okay wow so i'm excited to
test this thing out here uh well this
now i i feel like i'm really playing a
classical guitar at least just holding
it and looking at it's like okay this
this looks and feels like a classical
guitar the first one is kind of a toy
you know right i mean if it's the
difference between uh not playing the
guitar and playing a guitar i'd rather
have that 200 guitar nothing
if i can afford more
i'd rather have something more yeah
well let's let's hear it i'm curious
here i'll i'll actually get set up to
play it properly when i when i play all
the pieces back to back but just to get
a feel for it let's see what it's like
i'll play the same sore uh variation
okay there's some resonance at least i
hear you know something that really
responds instantly
[Music]
that really sounds like a guitar
especially after the 200 window yeah
it's got that nice resonance
it has a blend of tone colors that are
accessible yes the thick base but also
the clarity on top that 200 guitar
really had no resonance on bottom
no it it didn't really have resonance on
the bottom it didn't really have
resonance on the top and it didn't have
too much in the middle either
other than that it's great other than
that
but here
i really feel like
the instrument when i pluck i i feel the
vibration against my chest
so already at two thousand dollars we
really have something that sounds like a
real uh
i mean we're getting now we can make
some art you know oh absolutely uh there
are a lot of people
in schools and performing who play on
instruments of this caliber yeah you
know this is kind of if you want to
classify it as a concert quality
instrument this is kind of the very very
beginnings of the concert quality
instrument right
i don't think that there's anybody who
would play it full time as their concert
instrument but you know if you're going
to be playing a wedding outdoors or
something like that where you know uncle
larry is going to drop some wine on your
guitar this is really not a bad place to
be you know as a concert quality for
years i played and when i was in college
my instrument was actually a little bit
cheaper than this one uh and i learned
on it and i survived and i fell in love
with classical guitar music you know i
think we just need an instrument that
doesn't block us at every turn it
doesn't fight us at every musical moment
and especially an instrument that has
good playability because if the action's
too high you're just going to be
developing tension unnecessary tension
so for me again playability is the most
important thing everything else is extra
you know absolutely yeah and you know i
remember your guitar very well
and you know this is definitely a step
up from where you started out as and
where i saw you progress
uh in your earlier years
we've known each other forever it's been
a long time
well yeah my first guitar was uh
something i bought at guitar center it
was very shiny it looked like it was
sprayed by
10 different layers of shellac and then
they went over a couple more couple more
probably so i could see my face and i
remember thinking like oh this is a good
guitar it's like super shiny it had
mother of pearl everywhere so i mistook
the beautiful look uh for a good guitar
and it was also very high so you know
high it must be just good right of
course
so be careful uh don't be you know um
swayed by a beautiful looking instrument
it's gotta sound good and feel good most
importantly and this one i do i really
like the sound
so i mean in the 2000 range i mean this
thing actually like you say i think you
could go through college degrees and
even play some professional gigs on this
and and you can make good music oh
absolutely this is a fine musical piece
if you only have two thousand dollars
this is a really great place to be uh
you can get a new guitar for
you know that's maybe not quite as good
for right around the same price
but
this one actually
is musical
i was just also getting lost in this
beautiful um these beautiful like wooden
pegs and actually some kind of nice
designs here and the machine heads too
so it's got it's got its uh you know
charm this guitar i wonder if maybe i
was thinking since it has this nice base
range i'm saying you can take it down to
drop d
and hearing some um your baby
[Music]
beautiful sound i think the timbre is
really lovely but uh playability wise
because that action i'm not having a
good time because it's uh especially
when i got up here everything is too
difficult you know yeah yeah no this
also has a very old style set up right
and it can be changed although at a
guitar at this price point it's not
necessarily worth the work that goes
into it and we highly often recommend
putting those resources to a better
allocation that makes sense more
expensive get taller
cool okay well i i do dig the sound of
this one and later on we'll hear again
more pieces on each one but uh i'm very
interested if this is what two thousand
dollars feels like the 200 to 2 000 was
a huge change i'm very curious now what
is a 20 000 guitar feeling a guitar a
guitar oh what
it's not a bass or something
well we'll get davey in here okay david5
before i'll have to let us know
all right so at 20 000
this is
an r.e brunei
37 houser copy he hasn't done too many
of these
so your dad made this yeah my dad made
this the
37 hauser this is based off of the
iconic guitar that segovia played right
and uh he's the only person who has made
drawings of that 37 houser so anybody
who offers a 37 hauser they're all built
off of the plans that my father drew
wow
so uh here it is that's beautiful it's a
beautiful guitar it's got brazilian
rosewood sides and back oh yeah wow it's
got a bear claw spruce i tell you wood
like that just doesn't grow on trees
anymore
i love the top this is so beautiful
would you call it their club yeah this
is called bear claw or hazelficta uh if
you're a german hustler yeah
households and baron victors okay
wow well i'm
now very excited to play i don't know i
was going to play one of your dads
[Music]
you know like
a few notes and the quality difference
for me i'm not sure how much of that is
coming across but the feel of it the
timbre the ease of playing is really uh
a night and day
it's got a lot of overtones yeah that's
exactly right
[Music]
listen that's a stain also gorgeous it's
still going yeah
yeah let's just wait yeah
you want to go grab lunch while it does
its thing and i saw a pizzeria okay
let's go
it's really beautiful
let me try that mozart variation thing
is that
we'll hear a little bit on each
instrument
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
wow the clarity
[Music]
is like so incredible i even have like
pinissimo
[Music]
it's like super clear
it's precise yeah
wow
[Music]
is this is what i meant when i talked
about guitars that do have the playing
for you i mean
[Music]
i feel like it's guiding me anyways
[Music]
beautiful resonance
i mean some of this i know is not is
hard to come across on on a recording
but i can tell you with my experience
playing lots of different guitars the
jump from the last guitar to this guitar
might not be as objective over uh by
audio but the feel is as much difference
as from the 200 to 2000. well they say
that the first five thousand dollars is
for the audience and everything after
that is for the player that's exciting
but
it and it does it makes perfect sense
with that
everything beyond that
translates a lot or not everything but a
lot of it afterwards translates into the
response into the player which allows a
player to express their
musical thoughts
a lot easier
it frees up mental bandwidth so that way
when you are playing something like this
you don't have to worry about is my
finger going to be in the right place
how hard do i have to hit this note it
becomes instinctive it becomes an
extension of you well said that's
exactly my experience uh and the freer
you are in that moment on stage to then
just let the intentions flow from your
mind to the audience's ears you know all
the mediums this is just a tool right at
the end of the day these are tools
but we want the tool to be as invisible
as possible we want the immediacy of the
intention to reach the audience
uninhibited you know and i feel like
when i have guitars like this that's
what's happening oh yeah so it's just i
think you said it very nicely
let's check the sustain up here
[Music]
so what i love about this guitar is
compared to the first guitar is we hear
the fundamental
the actual note you're perceiving
after we hear that we get all this extra
overtones here check this out
[Music]
so the fundamentals gone
but i still hear
this
halo of overtones that it's sympathetic
resonation right yeah well you yeah
exactly you get this beautiful evolution
of sound as a transitions from the
fundamental because when you're dealing
in that range and that octave the
fundamental goes away fairly quickly
yeah as you heard on the 200 guitar
exactly i mean that thing is all
fundamental and it goes tink
and it's got the grace of dropping a
wrench onto a piece of concrete uh
this one it has this evolution of sound
yeah where it goes it transitions from
fundamentals to overtones and then all
the overtones flow in around to support
the note that isn't there
in a way that enhances
the
non-existent well said i think we can
isolate this and make it more obvious if
you're having a hard time hearing it
i'll play the e then i'll immediately
stop the fundamental so everything
you're hearing after i stop the note is
all extra overtones so
[Music]
all of that is just what's ringing it's
the overtones we're hearing it's just a
beautiful sound
it's gorgeous it's incredible yeah so
that's what's happening all the time
when you're playing you produce
different overtones depending on where
you are and so
you have this background halo around all
the notes you're playing that are
producing those sounds
[Music]
well this is a really incredible
instrument i'm looking forward to trying
it out uh back to back with all these uh
the pieces at the end here but let's
just let's talk a bit more now about uh
about our last guitar because you know
200 dollars dollars 20 000 that's
already pretty extreme i haven't i
haven't bought a 20 000 from it before
but yeah 200 000 yen
actually just one on sale
for you
i'll throw in a case
all of our guitars come with cases i'll
do it if you throw in a capo you got it
okay so
i mean it's just a work of art you know
and same with your instruments uh that
you've made that the recent instruments
you've that i've seen you make i mean
are of the same quality just they're
it's really incredible to to look at and
to interplay marshall so thank you thank
you for for letting me play this one now
i don't even know how how can you get
better than this i'm so interested to
see what well let's add a zero and go
from there no big deal instead of zero
what we're going to do is we're going to
go from
a bench copy of a 37 houser
to an actual 1936 houser
wow okay well so we're going to go from
our
modern
exact copy
to the real deal
let's do it all right
so
we have the next guitar
two hundred thousand dollars ready you
ready
[Music]
1936 house
that's beautiful
and this is
this is the guitar it's got a few
scratches on the back uh as my old boss
used to say that's just character right
yeah those are love love bites
uh and it's got uh two cracks on it oh
and that's it
they've been expertly repaired
uh
minor minor playing where uh
this is pretty close to as pristine as
you can get i've had a couple without
the cracks and they're obviously a bit
more expensive because
you know at this point we're grading
based off of
structural condition and basically it's
cumulative life up to this point
so this is not the most perfect one i've
had
but it's really really really close it's
really good oh man
super excited to play this it's light it
is but it's actually not
all that far off from the other guitars
in terms of of the weight but what
you're feeling is the balance of the
guitar oh interesting it's it's a north
south
east-west balance right and when you put
it up to your chest you'll actually
notice that it settles into your body it
doesn't want to fall away from you all
right
and when it's up properly
the weight tends to disappear off of
them
that's incredible
i've never experienced that before
i was also just enjoying the i know this
name herman hauser i i you know know
about luthier just to see the original
label is also a beautiful thing herman
hauser guitar in munchen
incredible 1936. wow
um well let's see if we're in tune
sweet sounding e
[Music]
okay so just in tuning this thing i'm
kind of blown away
i didn't expect to be that blown away by
it
wow
like
you know there are pieces you can play
where you go hey this is a little bit
easier but just to play the open strings
and go whoa
yeah and beyond that
you know this is
with this guitar you can actually hear
the guitars behind us resonating with it
and that's because
the way that he built he created
this inertia of sound they're not loud
guitars yeah
super loud
but wow there's this energy and constant
push behind the sound yeah
[Music]
it's got that clarity of your dad's
guitar but with a different feel
that's wisdom
[Music]
well
i think the thing about that i'm really
feeling with this is like
like we were saying that playability
thing it's like i i feel like i'm doing
maybe 25 of the work i was doing with
that 200 guitar so that's the main
reason uh i i the main thing i look for
guitar but i mean obviously i'm not
going to be buying a 200 guitar in time
soon but i mean wow the the difference
is again night and day
[Music]
let's try that yobet piecing i'm really
interested to hear what it sounds like
in drop d
[Music]
it's so sweet it's like i feel like it's
asking me to play softer more dolce
well there's a reason why yeoman played
on a hauser
did he yeah i didn't know yeah it was
like a homecoming for that piece so
you know this is history this is beyond
just a musical instrument there are no
more hauser ones being made and there
haven't been for a long time there can
only be less of these
right you know hence the value right
well i could just keep playing these
instruments but i am so ready to play
them back to back so you guys can get a
chance to really hear uh you know the
same pieces back-to-back and how they
how they sound so get your headphones
ready if you can i want to thank you
marshall for uh
setting me up with these beautiful
guitars to try out today and uh is there
anything that you wanted to mention to
to my channel absolutely my pleasure and
thanks for coming uh yeah uh please feel
free to visit me me brunei dot com uh
you can call me visit me uh i make
guitars i'm sure as you've seen
elsewhere very good guitars
and uh
you know there i'll have a promo code of
brandon on my website that will give you
500 off of a deposit for a guitar
uh so feel free to take advantage of
that
and uh
just come on by give us a call we're
happy to share these instruments with
you at any time as well you know there's
a lot more that we haven't touched on
and you know whatever your budget is
uh
we'll help you find something great
we'll leave a link in the bio so you can
check out his website well thanks
marshall my pleasure thanks brandon all
right let's get to playing
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you